Let's look at the solution for our BTB quiz. The question was,
which BTB entry is used for a particular PC. It might seem
easy because we need 10 bits to index into this BTB, so we will just take
the least significant 10 bits of this PC. And index into the BTB with that.
However, note that instructions are fixed size four bytes, and were the line,
which means that not all addresses are possible for the program counter.
If you now look at what would happen if we used the least significant 10-bits to
index into the BTB, we would see the the entry number zero would be used.
An instruction can have the least significant 10 bits be all zero. Entry number
one, however, requires the least significant 10 bits to be 000001 and
that entry cannot be used because the instructions are word-aligned. As we said,
addresses such as all zeros and then just one are not possible. Basically,
all addresses actually need to be not only even. But also divisible by four.
So if you take the lower most bits that means that the only
possible instruction addresses are of the form something something something and
then the least significant two bits say zero.
That means that we are really using only every fourth entry in our BTB.
Pretty much of the 1024 entry BTB we are really using only 256 entries
which is a huge waste. So in this case what should happen is we should not use
the least significant ten bits, and instead we use these ten bits so
that the least-significant bits that can be different among instructions.
Basically these bits are always zero so they're just going to waste entries.
We need to take the least significant ten bits that are still different among
different instructions. So in this case our instruction has bits C is 1100.
Zero is 0000. B is 1011. We're going
to ignore these two bits. And take the next one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten bits. So this is the index into our BTB.
And now let's convert that to hex, this will be the first hex digit so,
it will be three. This will be the next hex digit, so it will be c.
And this will be two. So we are talking about the entry number 2c3.